("The Best" by Tina Turner)
- Alrighty,
ladies and gentlemen,
boys and girls, we're here.
If you know who's
about to come out stage,
I know you're excited.
He's one of the hottest speakers
on the planet right now.
Just like what we do here,
this man builds businesses.
Fresh out of college,
took his family wine
business from three million
to 60 million, in less
than four or five years.
Along the way,
he's become an incredibly
successful venture
capitalist, an angel investor,
invested in a couple
of small companies
you may have heard of,
called Facebook
and Twitter, and Uber.
He's got a brand new book coming out
very soon, it's called #AskGaryVee,
because he is Gary Vee.
Ladies and gentlemen, please be
on your feet and welcome to the stage,
the last speaker for ICON 2016,
give it up for Gary Vaynerchuk.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Gary Vee!
(energetic rap music)
(laughs)
(speaker is drowned out by loud music)
- Thank you so much.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
So, (audience member cheers).
Thank you!
How's everybody?
(audience cheers)
Awesome.
Couple things,
first, I was asked very politely
not to curse, so they'll
be no cursing. (laughter)
(audience boos)
It's just the truth.
Second of all, because I wanna figure out
where I wanna take this talk,
based on the crowd,
how many people in this room
don't know who I am and don't have
a good feel for my spiel?
Please raise your hand.
Alright, that hurts. (laughter)
Makes sense.
Alright, so I'm gonna go very quickly,
since it's not that big of a percentage,
then I'm gonna go into my spiel,
and then I honestly wanna go into Q and A,
as quickly as possible, because I think
70% of you have heard a lot of this,
the 30% of you are gonna enjoy it,
but I think if we can go into
the context and the details,
it'll be far greater.
So, actually, I'm gonna go
with a very short version
of it, 'cause there
wasn't that many hands.
I was born in the Soviet Union,
so I grew up an immigrant.
What that means is,
how many people here
were not born in America?
Raise your hand.
Wow, let's clap it up for the immigrants
in the house.
(audience cheers)
I like that.
Oh actually this is very international,
you flew in, you don't live here,
got it, sorry, I screwed up.
Okay, so, I grew up very poor,
I lived in a studio apartment
with eight family members,
so I've got grit, right?
Like, I'm not scared to work,
I think one of the biggest problems
right now, is we're living through
one of the great generations
of fake entrepreneurship,
because so many people are able
to raise money, and so you've got,
you just have people
that are not supposed
to be running businesses,
running businesses,
'cause there was so much capital
for the last seven or eight years,
and that's interesting for me to watch,
though the stuff is
starting to hit the fan,
so, that will play itself out.
I was a hustler, I know
stuff, I know, (laughter)
I was a hustler from the get,
I was lemonade stand, baseball cards,
all that stuff, so I was
really a salesperson,
through and through.
When I was 12, I was making two
to $3,000 a weekend,
selling baseball cards
in the malls of New Jersey,
and I don't know about you guys,
but when you have $30,000 in cash,
under your bed, and you're 14 years old,
and you're not selling weed,
you're doing a good job.
(laughter and applause)
So, that was me.
My dad dragged me into the liquor store
that he now owned, he was
making two bucks an hour
as a stockboy, when he first came
to America, so you can imagine
how much my parents are
very much my heroes.
He owned a small store,
really not much bigger
than the stage I'm on, it
was a 400 square foot store,
then he built it up, made it bigger,
I was dragged into it.
I hated it.
It was not fun for me,
I'd bagged ice for 15 hours a day,
I was in the basement.
How many people here have seen
the movie Goonies?
Raise your hand. (audience cheers)
I literally like was Sloth
for like three years. (laughter)
I was basically chained to the basement
of my dad's liquor store. It sucked.
Finally I was allowed upstairs
and I realized that people collected wine
and that was my connection to the world
I came from, with baseball cards
and things of that
nature, and that started
kind of my interest
into my dad's business.
'Cause at that point I was
a punk entrepreneur kid,
I thought I could run the
business better than my dad,
but I wasn't interested in
selling Coors Light and Absolut,
but this wine thing was interesting,
and it felt like the marketing thing
that I couldn't define at that point,
storytelling, bullcrapping,
whatever you want to call it,
like, I couldn't figure out what I was,
but I knew I was somethin',
and I knew that it wasn't interesting
to deploy that against Coors Light
or an Absolut, but the wine thing,
most people didn't understand,
there was an opportunity to really market.
So I, from 17 to 18 years old,
16 to 18 years old, I
probably learned more
about wine than most
people should ever learn
in their lives, I was a terrible student,
I started getting F's in fourth grade,
I punted it very early in my life.
I would tell you that I
if could wish anything
for everybody in this
conference right now,
if I could actually wish you anything
besides health, that would be number one,
but if I could wish you
anything besides health,
I would wish you self-awareness.
I truly believe that
self-awareness (audience applauds),
self-awareness is a big deal
and my self-awareness
was extreme as a kid,
and I just knew who I was,
and even though the market.
Don't forget, I was an immigrant,
so the way out for immigrants
in America, for a lot of you
that don't know, is education,
they push it hard.
(audience member shouts)
So all my friends, my parents' friends
were pushing education,
all the other Russian kids
went to Yale, and if
they were like a loser
they went to NYU. (laughter)
I was like getting F's, but my parents
supported my entrepreneurship,
but more importantly than that,
I was gifted, 'cause I really,
I'm trying to figure out how to teach it
or elevate it, because it's a big deal,
but I was gifted with self-awareness
by 12 or 13, even though
all my friends' parents
told me I was a loser, 'cause
I was failling classes,
even though my teachers said that,
I knew, I knew because
I was making a crapload
of cash every weekend (laughter).
But I also knew because
I just could taste it,
I knew who I was.
So, anyway, I got involved
in my dad's liquor store,
my plan was not to go to college,
my mom, this is how much my mom
didn't know about the education system
in America. My mom came to me
in February of my graduating
year of high school.
You know, you're graduating in 90 days
and goes to me, "So what
are we doing about college?"
I'm like, I've been doing
a lot of things mom,
I'm not going, and then
she punched me in the face
and (laughter), like a
couple of days later I,
this is not a joke, this
is how I went to college,
a couple days later, I got a postcard
in the mail from Mount Ida College,
and I filled out my name and address
and send it in and that's
how I went to college.
So, that fall I went to Mount Ida College
in Newton, Mass, I was in my dorm room
on a very faithful day,
playing Madden '95,
dominating by the way, (laughter)
my boy comes in (chuckles), and says,
"Hey, you gotta come see this,"
I went into a dorm room,
there's eight dudes,
they're standing over a computer,
I had a word processor for the papers
I was supposed to do.
So I, at this point, I'm 18 years old,
I've spent maybe 30
minutes on the Internet,
excuse me, I'm sorry, 30 minutes
on a computer in my life.
I'm old, so like that's
how we did it, right?
And so, I'm standing in
front of the computer,
I understand, at this point
the information super highways
in the news, I hear for the first time
(loud mouth beeping),
is 1994, (laughter) I'm like,
is this the Internet?
The information super highway, oh my god!
I, eight dudes are standing
over an AOL chatroom
for five hours, I waited three hours
for my turn, (laughter)
I get on the Internet,
and within seven minutes,
and I could barely use a computer,
I still can't type,
like, in seven minutes,
I'm on a random AOL message board
where people are selling
and trading baseball cards.
And within 30 minutes of ever being
on the Internet in 1994,
I realized, holy crap, I don't need
to open up 4,000 liquor stores,
I'm gonna sell on this thing.
And that's my relationship
with the Internet. (audience applauds)
Don't clap, 'cause I didnt' accomplish
anything yet, but here
it comes. (laughter)
I figured out, I started
getting super interested,
I, like, you know?
When I came back from, we
didn't have cell phones,
and you didn't know your
friend's phone numbers
back then, like when I
came back from school
that summer, I found a couple nerds
from high school, I was like, yo, nerds,
you know this crap, right?
They're like, "Yeah," I'm like, alright,
like, I went to their
house, they got like a modem
in their phone, they're weird as hell,
it's in the basement, it's awkward,
but I'm like, this is it.
And so (laughter), two years later,
I launch the second
e-commerce wine business
in America, called winelibrary.com.
And so, it's comin', (laughter)
and then in 1998, actually
this is a good story,
this will, you know what?
This is a good story for a lot of people
in this room, you know, I've audited
a lot of people in this room,
looking at people using the hashtags,
I've spoke here three or four years ago,
I've got a solid sense of
what's going on in here.
I'm really excited
because this little story
I'm about to tell, actually,
I've never said it this way,
Joe Mama, I see you brother.
A lot of people have heard this before,
I'm actually gonna tie this in nicely.
I would tell you the most
interesting thing for me,
in this room today, is the following,
I believe that I'm standing in a room
of non-marketers or brand people.
Non!
I think I'm sitting in the room
of transactional salespeople,
and by the way, I like that,
just so everybody knows,
I'm not saying that's bad or good,
but I feel that the far majority
of this room are transactioners.
One of the biggest reasons
that there is a stunning
disrespect for social media
in this room
is because the far
amount of people here
work on quant and transactions
and data and
short-term business metrics,
not on brand and marketing,
and long-term business metrics.
So, I'm gonna break that
down, (low clapping)
thanks back there, one
person was clapping,
he's pumped! (laughter)
So, (chuckles) this is what happened,
and this is why I launched winelibrary.com
in 1996, just remember.
How many people here, over the age of 38?
Raise your hands.
Love it.
So, a good portion of you remember
what I remember, which was,
and by the way, some of you thought this,
people thought the Internet itself
was a fad, not Snapchat or Twitter,
the whole damn thing. (laughter)
So, I remember literally giving a talk
in 1996 at the Chamber of Commerce
of like, I launched a dot-com,
and like people making fun of me,
I literally was on a panel with a guy
who sold Yellow Pages, (laughter)
and said that this kid, he said,
in a big crowd, no, small crowd,
but he goes, "How many of you
"in this section, how many of you
"have ever bought or will buy
anything from the Internet?"
And nobody raised their hand. (laughter)
I'm 22 years old, and he goes,
"And this kid is gonna tell you
"that you're gonna buy
wine on the Internet."
And everybody goes, ha
ha ha ha. (laughter)
So I'm sitting there, this is the part
where I really wish you let me curse,
but, (laughter)
(crowd cheers) so I go,
so I go,
so I go, and this is funny,
and this is interesting
how the world played out,
I said, this is actually my,
and I didn't realize how the world
was really gonna play out,
I said, you know I really wish
this was being recorded,
is what I said.
I said, because you're gonna be
on the wrong side of history.
The biggest problem and slash
the biggest opportunity to make
and lose money is, most people sitting
in this room, just a straight fact,
are projecting all their decision-making
completely predicated on how the world
is right this second, without projecting
or deploying emerging consumer behaviors.
I, for a fact, stand here today
knowing that 20 years from today,
which, depending on
how you think about it,
is a long time or a short time,
feels short to me, 'cause I'll see it,
I won't be dead.
20 years from today,
everybody in this room
will be living in a virtual reality world,
and I mean the people in
this room will be sitting
at home or whatever the
hell we're living in,
because we're now in a VR world,
probably all in San Diego,
'cause it's super nice
there, right? (laughter)
And you will literally
put on contact lenses
or whatever, it's not gonna
be this bullcrap Oculus,
it's gonna be contact lenses
and who knows what could happen in,
maybe, you know, LASIK
right into your eyeballs?
Right?
And you will sit there, and your brain
will believe what you're seeing
is real, as what's happening right now,
98.6%, by the best scientist right now,
you will believe it.
So let's take a step back,
in 20 years, you'll sit in a room,
and you will believe everything
that you're seeing, even though
it's not actually happening,
'cause we've all now lived life,
and you'll, 98.6% believe it.
There will be a point
in human beings' time,
where what we're doing right now
is gonna be debated as real life,
compared to what's going on there.
If you don't believe that,
then you haven't been paying attention
to how humans are
walking around the world,
looking at their phone all the time,
regardless of situation.
And though it was a social awkward thing
that we pushed against,
now the oldest of us are more than happy
to do it at all times in public.
My friends, the Internet, is the biggest
shift in our lives, ever,
more than the printing
press and caves, ever!
VR is coming and it will
be the next platform.
I will probably buy the New York Jets
by my investments in VR,
but it's gonna take 20 years, right?
It's gonna take 20 years.
Right now a lot of people
are investing in it,
and they're gonna lose money,
just like all the people that tried
to invest in the Internet in '91, '92,
they thought it would
be done by 1995, 1997.
I made those same mistakes,
when I launched winelibrary.com in 1996,
I said, by the year
2000, 50% of my business
is gonna be online!
You know, it's still 33%.
And we were ahead of it,
and really bet on it,
so, you know?
And by the way, just to
put things into context,
e-commerce, things we buy and ship,
still only represent 15 to 17%
of all commerce in America.
All that prime still just adds up to that.
So, things happen faster and sooner,
but what I wanna talk about
is why I launched winelibrary.com.
I launched it in 1996,
and the first two years,
that business did about $1,000
in sales, in two years.
I was still in school, nobody even knew
what a computer was back
at the liquor store,
so it did $1,000.
We paid $15,000 to build it.
I don't know how many of you
have a Soviet father, (laughter)
but Sasha Vaynerchuk wasn't happy
with that ROI. (laughter)
It's the same way so many people
in here, when they talk about Snapchat
or other things of that nature,
wanna know what the ROI is today.
Winelibrary.com, from 1998 to 2003,
in a five year window helped me grow
my dad's business, and
let's break this down,
this was a $3,000,000 a year business,
that was making 10% gross profit,
so it was making $300,000
in profit before expenses.
Now luckily, Sasha didn't
pay anybody anything
so he got to take home
150K or what have you.
And he was investing
and owning the property
and that was his, he made it, right?
Came into this country with
two bucks, so, he made it!
I grew that business, no cash infusion,
no raising money,
no M&amp;A, no partnership.
With no money, I grew that business
from a three to a 65
million dollar business
in five years. (crowd cheers)
I did that on what I wanna talk
to you about today.
I guess I put it up in my slide now.
I suck crap at 99.9%
of things in my life,
I'm crap, I'm bad,
I don't know much.
Really, I'm pretty like,
I'm stunningly undereducated,
right? (laughter)
You know what it is?
I do have huge EQ,
my emotional intelligence
is through the roof,
that's why I'm gonna be a billionaire,
'cause EQ is more important than IQ.
So that's good, but, (crowd cheers)
but, this is the only thing I do.
What I, now that I'm 40,
I finally figured out what do I do
for a living, that's what I do.
I, day trade attention.
That's what I do.
So, my career was, I thought e-commerce
was gonna big in 1996, the market didn't,
I bought e-commerce, in
essence, follow me here,
I bought, I paid a lot for the site,
don't go tactical, go
higher level with me,
I bought into e-commerce,
which meant all my behavior,
I didn't try to make more money
and buy a second liquor store,
I tried to make a lot of money
and build a website.
I bought e-commerce in '96, '97, '98, '99,
when the market didn't believe in it.
Then I started and I bought
into email marketing.
How many people here have done
email marketing in their careers?
Raise your hand. (crowd cheers)
Great!
I did, I, in 1996, in mid-1997,
I had a 200,000 person email newsletter
for a wine store,
that had 91.3% open rates.
- [Voiceover] Wow!
- Yeah, and by the way,
I'm not fancy, like, thanks for your wows
or whatever, here's why,
I day trade attention.
Nobody else was doing email marketing,
so people, you know, one more time,
how many people here are 38 and older?
Right, good, we're old in here,
so stick with me (laughter),
you guys remember this,
remember all old dudes and chicks?
Remember what you did with email
the first couple years we had it?
We read, (loud clap) youngsters
there's a lot of you, too,
youngsters, we read every
(loud claps) single email
and every word of every email
for four years! (laughter)
Because more than I know that the sun
will come up tomorrow, I know
that marketers ruin everything!
(laughter)
It's what we do!
And it's because we day trade attention.
I started email marketing,
that helped me, as you
can imagine, quite a bit.
How many people here have
bought Google AdWords
in their career, believe in that?
Good.
The day it launched, I
bought the word wine,
for five cents a click,
because the minimum
wasn't 10 cents yet, and I owned it
for nine and a half months
before anybody bid me up.
Because I was day trading this thing
called Google AdWords while everybody
was talking about what's the ROI,
let me, that's not true.
For the first two years,
nobody knew what it was,
they didn't know it existed,
they were still in Yahoo
and freaking askjeeves.com.
(laughter)
(chuckles)
So, and then, while people debated,
"Does this work, what is this?"
I was just doing it, as a matter of fact,
I would tell you the
fundamental biggest mistake
of my career was not spending
all my money on Google AdWords,
the reason Wine Library,
you'll like this, Wine Library right now,
for the first time in its existence
under my watch, is spending every dollar
on just one marketing behavior,
only Facebook ads.
No Google AdWords, shifting it,
only Facebook, because what I learned
from Google in 2002 and 2003,
is changing my behavior,
which was, when something
is grossly underpriced
by the market, because
people aren't practitioners.
Do you know how many people in this room
have strong public opinions
on Facebook ads, have talked crap
these last three days about Facebook ads
and have never run Facebook ads?
'Cause that's what
we have a room full of,
headline readers,
non-practitioners,
or practitioners in one craft
that has made them money,
so they love it so much,
like it's their first
girlfriend (laughter), right?
You get romantic about
how you made your money,
you were good at email marketing,
so know you want it
to be good forever,
you were good at Google AdWords,
so you wanna be good forever,
you were good at affiliate marketing,
so you wanted to be good forever.
But that's not how markets work!
Right, so your affiliate marketing
and Google AdWords and email marketing
disrupted other things.
There were older dudes than you
that loved direct mail
and magazine copyrighting
and horsecrap like that. (laughter)
And then you came along,
in your younger years and said,
"This Google thing's good."
And now you're not happy,
but you refuse to look at data
like, oh, I don't know, Google themselves
putting out data that Google AdWords
are down 19% in clicking,
because we've gotten used to it.
Sally, Arkansas, doesn't
go to Google anymore
and click every ad, every time.
Got it?
And, by the way, I'll come
back five years from now,
ICON 2021, and be asked
not to curse and (laughter),
and I'll come here and say,
you guys are still
spending money on Facebook?
You idiots!
The market is shifted,
because I day trade attention,
I have no romance for any marketing
or business behavior and never will,
to the day I die, period.
And that's a very important
statement that so few
in this room actually deeply believe.
And if you did, then you would never
disrespect anything new that has
150 million
active monthly users,
like Snapchat, because it doesn't
have a click-out function,
so you can figure out
what the conversion rate is.
(laughter)
We are living in two
very separate worlds,
the reason I am
going to make billions
and have made
hundreds of millions
and the reason many in
here will make millions
is 'cause there's a
difference between sales
and transactions and
brand and marketing.
Got it?
And here, (loud clapping) you're
welcome! (audience cheers)
And here's why I'm here, not to say,
oh I'm so cool and I make more than you,
'cause plenty of you
will make more than me,
it's not that, it's that
if you just gave an ounce
of respect that brand matters,
you know, if you just looked at what
you were wearing right now
and realized that's why
you bought it. (laughter)
If you just gave it a little respect,
and you just cut yourself a little bit
out of being just pure math arbitrators,
if you just did that, if you just realized
it was in your best financial interest
to take 20% of your moneys and behaviors
and learn new things.
And learn 'em!
You would make so much more success
out of your businesses.
So much more.
Instead of doing the easy route,
that has happened time and time again,
you're gonna poo-poo the new thing,
there's so much value in figuring out
what's happening on musical.ly,
and After School and Anchor and Peach.
Do I spend all my time in that?
No, two, three percent
but the behaviors
that I learned on Socialcam,
which crashed and burned
in four minutes, were the foundation
of what I learned to make Vine videos
and Instagram 15-second videos,
which have deployed and created
enourmous amounts of money for me.
You're learning a skill,
do you think the world's
gonna just stand still
and never evolve?
And so, we're making a lot of mistakes
in this collective room,
because we're stuck
in a math game.
The same stuff that put
Zynga and LivingSocial
in a really bad place.
So it's fine if you're playing
at a micro, micro level and that's cute,
and that's cool, and do you,
and everybody's got different wants
and needs in life, but please,
please understand that the market
doesn't care about you.
When I saw Uber, before I
invested in it, I called my dad.
When my dad came to America,
he went to New Jersey,
but some of you may know,
if you lived in the L.A. area,
a lot of Russians moved to L.A.,
and they went into the cab business,
they were, you know?
These are men, these are my dad's friends,
by the way, these are men that came
to America with no money,
and started being cab drivers,
making two bucks an hour.
Right?
They built up, you know,
immigrants are really good at one thing?
Not spending money on dumb crap, right?
So, they save their money forever,
and they buy medallion
and a car and they build.
So, I see this thing and I'm like,
man this Uber thing's gonna,
and not at first, I
didn't see it at first,
that's a little bit later,
but then when it, it happened fast.
Like, San Francisco first market,
the numbers were like ten x
what they projected like week,
I mean, it happened fast, right?
We all know what Uber is.
So, I call my dad, I said,
dad, I gotta call your friend Madic
and Nikolai and Vladimir and all
those cliche Russian names (laughter)
and I said, I gotta call your homies.
And so, I did, he gave me the number,
and I called them.
Now these are men that I love,
these are like pseudo-uncles,
these are my dad's best friends,
these are men that came to this country,
worked their face off for 30 years,
they're finally in their late 50s and 60s,
and they finally have
fleet of cars, right?
They're getting residual,
they're finally got their boats
and, I have my dad's DNA,
my dad's a workaholic,
he's gonna work,
but a lot of these guys
are startin' to chill a little bit
after 30 years,
they can enjoy themselves.
And I call them, and I go, look,
this thing, Uber, and
I explained it to them,
like, you take your phone and,
I mean, you know?
Right?
I'm like, the phone, they'll come.
And they're like, "Boychik,
boychik, boychik. (laughter)
"That's very cute, right?
"But, da-da-da-da-da-da-da,"
I said, okay, cool.
36 months later these mens' businesses
are literally, 36 months,
after 30 years of working
every day, 36 months later,
these guys' businesses are worth
between a nickel to a dime
on the dollar that it was 36 months ago.
Guys, innovation doesn't give a crap
about you or me.
You're just in the way.
And what most of you do
is you wanna hold ground
as it comes directly in your face.
My friends, can we all agree
this is an important device in life?
Can we agree, can you (mumbles)
agree with me on this?
- [Voiceover] Yes!
- Do you know that 53% of
every person's attention,
the collective, on this device
is spent on social networks?
53%, you have games, movies,
calendars, runner aps,
53% of our collective,
and not teenage girls
in Manhattan, 53% of the collective
is spending time on social media.
Oh, I'm sorry, social media, A.K.A.
the slang term for the current state
of the Internet.
So, I can stand here and tell you
of 50, not four, not one, 50 businesses
that I'm associated with
that are converting sales,
leads, transactions, money,
better on Facebook than on Google,
or banner retargeting right now.
I can, flat out, best in class e-com guys,
how many people here are
familiar with the app Wish?
Raise your hand.
Raise it, I wanna see how many of you,
raise it high, I wanna see.
So, good, Wish, the fastest
growing e-commerce product
in the world. Huge in every
country in the world.
It is founded by 13 members,
but three core founders, that were all
on Google's AdWords team.
Every dollar they have spent
to build the biggest shopping app
in the world has been on Facebook.
My personal trainer, Mike, (chuckles)
has made more transactions
to his $400 a month online course
through Snapchat content
in the last 90 days
than he has on Facebook ads, Twitter,
Google AdWords, affiliate
and Instagram combined,
in 18 months.
This is not headline reading,
this is not hyperbole,
this is not curiosity,
this is not the future,
this is happening right now.
Here's the fundamental difference,
Mike's a better practitioner
in Snapchat content
than he was in the other stuff.
There is a land grab going on right now
on Snapchat, because people don't know
who to follow, there is no functionality,
so, he gets that awareness.
And we've watched
this very carefully,
so much of it is not
even coming from me,
I'm on purpose not giving
him as much shout-outs
as possible, 'cause I want
to see it naturally happen.
I just want everybody in this room
to understand, I'm not predicting here,
I'm telling you the past,
the past will tell you the future.
It's always the same
game, it's happening right
in front of your eyes,
you're going out every night,
when you go out every night, every night,
and you go to the restaurant or a bar,
when people are
opening up their phone
and going to Instagram or Snapchat,
they're not searching on Google.
They're not going on a random site
that has an affiliate link,
they're not getting pumped
to go on their phone
and click a banner ad.
How many people in this room
have never, on purpose,
'cause those X's are small,
how many people in
this room have never,
on purpose, clicked a banner ad
on their mobile device?
Raise your hand, everybody.
(laughter)
I mean, you're living one way,
you're living one way
as a human being,
and you're marketing a separate way,
and in that arbitrage comes
going out (loud claps) of business.
It may not happen today.
It may not happen tomorrow
but it is full-on happening.
And it's happening because of a couple
of different things,
early consumer behavior,
I can't believe what
I'm about to tell you,
I now no longer travel with a laptop.
For the last three weeks,
no, a little bit more,
last, for this actually, this year,
every trip I've taken, I've
only taken with my phone.
I now do everything I do on my phone.
It, that's insane, like, to me.
Even to me, that only preaches this,
like, I can't believe that.
Like, when you think about
your conversion rates
and your funnel, and your optimization
on your dot-com desktop versus mobile,
go look at those numbers
when you get home,
see how that math works out for you.
My friends, I implore you,
whether you agree with
this hyperbole or not,
take five hours, it's not a lot of time,
and please understand that shifts
are happening very quickly,
and it is super cliche
why people lose because they don't adapt
to current market behaviors,
not because they're not smart,
but because you started
making a couple of bucks
and you don't want it to go away.
Guys, the quickest way
to go out of business
is to be romantic about
how you make your money.
It's a big deal, you know?
You could have rah-rah.
You can have balloons
or whatever the hell you guys were
throwing up here,
rock music, give awards,
paper checks,
that's all fine and dandy.
You know what's
way more interesting?
The market.
The market is doing its thing,
and it's happening fast, and
you can get very confused,
very quickly, because normally
when you're playing
arbitrage, 'cause that's what
so many of you are playing,
normally, when you play arbitrage,
here's what it looks like.
And what I mean by arbitrage,
just to make sure I'm giving clarity is,
you're playing conversation base, right?
You're buying ads for this,
you're converting that,
it's just math, you're buying these leads
for that, whatever it is,
whether it's affiliate, or Google
or Facebook, it doesn't
matter, it's just quant, right?
It's just math, right?
Here's how those businesses look,
for all time, not today,
du-tu-tu-tu-tu-tu-tu-tu, pfiu.
And so, I come here with empathy
and try to get people to understand
that you have to pay attention
to where consumer's attention's going.
Where technology is going is more scary
for a lot of people in here,
that are not in the branding
and marketing business,
and are in the conversion business.
And again, conversion business, you know?
You're buying ads that lead to whatever
you're selling, supplements,
masterminds, e-books,
whatever the hell you're doing,
it's all that.
And let me tell you why,
because starting with this,
du-du-du-du-du, remember that?
TiVo?
When that happened, everything changed.
Watch this, this is for my
own personal gratification.
How many people in this
room, (clears throat)
when now watching television,
watch it on their time?
Meaning, outside of live sports,
TiVo, DVR, Netflix, when a show airs,
you don't watch it, you
watch it when you have time.
Raise your hand, everybody. (laughter)
How many of you, when given the option,
fast forward every single commercial?
Everybody.
My clients, at VaynerMedia,
Unilever, Pepsi,
Turner, Toyota, all the bigget brands
in the world spend 80 billion dollars
making commercials and
then distributing them
and not a soul in
America's watching them.
And even if they get lucky enough,
that you see it, because you're in bed
and your remote control
falls off your bed,
(laughter)
even if that happens, every person
in this room grabs their phone
and checks their work,
checks their Instagram,
sends a tweet, and then they sell you
on this bullcrap that, "But sports is
"still the last holy grail, right?"
Meanwhile, the highest engagement
on Twitter spikes always
are during commercial time
of big sporting events, 'cause everybody
wants to tweet about Steph
Curry's half-court shot.
Right?
So, while that mountain goes up this hill
or that cute girl tries
to sell you a soda,
you're paying attention to this, not that.
That same thesis of technology
that created fast forwarding,
because the only thing you guys
really care about is health comma money
comma your family comma, not in order,
or depends on how you roll, (laughter)
and finally, the one that most people
don't understand, the fourth one,
and it's the big one, and
it's the fastest growing one
in value, time.
You care about time,
and you don't realize it
but you're doing a lot of things
where you, if you broke down your life
the way I break down your life,
and you realize how much money
you're giving up for time,
you would go crazy.
You would not believe some
of the stuff you're doing,
'cause you value time so much,
that you're overpaying, I mean, it's.
I started doing something
that really bothered me,
I'm an immigrant that
came from nothing,
like four or five years ago,
I started leaving all the change
that I got back, on the counter.
And I was like, oh, god,
if my dad saw this, he would rip
my face off, right? (laughter)
You know?
All of it, 94 cents, one cent.
And somewhere around two years ago,
was like, oh my god, time,
like I, something that some of you,
how many people
have watched DailyVee?
Raise your hand.
Appreciate it. (crowd cheers)
You guys saw a couple of episodes ago,
I don't tie my shoes, ever. (laughter)
Time, I'll tie time if
like I finally settle down
and I'm, but I would never be walking
and stop and tie them.
Time, and time's why we
fast forward commercials,
and time is why technology is gonna
be built like ad blockers,
like what's going on now
where everything on a mobile device
that is either an affiliate or an ad
or a click to something you don't want,
Outbrain, Taboola, that world,
will not be in front of you,
'cause Apple doesn't need that money.
Got it?
Please understand, the reason
so many of you like
me because I'll answer
your questions any time,
I'm not trying
to have like gated wall
or a mastermind,
yes, every three years I sell a book
for $19, kill me, but for the most part,
(laughter) for the most part,
it all is me giving away?
Yeah, I'm a good guy,
mom and dad had
sex at the right moment
and gave me nice guy DNA.
(laughter)
But there's another reason I do it,
it's 'cause I'm building a brand,
I'm building a brand.
(audience cheers)
I'm not tryin' to transact
you at every corner,
like every other.
Do you know how
many people right now
are running ads for
Snapchat crash courses
for 300 bucks, who are completely
just ripping off my free content
and packaging it up and then are fans
of me and saying, "This is great,"
and then doing this bullcrap?
So, my friends, my friends,
it's fine, and I will never stand here
and begrudge how anybody
makes their money,
you do you, but I stand
here in front of you today,
ICON, caring about my brand forever.
Caring about my legacy forever,
caring more about
how I made my money,
than how much I made.
(audience cheers)
And, what the dirty little secret is
of that little Mother Teresa rant,
is not only do I get to
be a better human being
than most people, I actually
get to survive every shift
in technology, because I have a brand,
because I can go do the next platform,
because the day I decided to get serious
about Snapchat, I already had 9,000 views
on my snaps, 'cause I brought value,
not transactions, and this, my friends,
is a room full of transactors,
and that's the truth and you know it.
And it is what it is, and I'm telling you
it's not because I'm mad or
I wanna stand on top of you
and say, that's it.
I'm saying it because
I want you to win, I'm saying it because
what's great about
capitalism and marketing
and business is you
can change tomorrow
and it can change, but too many
are crippled by the money they make.
And what really pisses me off
is I have some real friends
that are transactors, making
hundreds of thousands,
millions of dollars, and I tell them,
shift it, you'll be safer, shift it!
And, they're like, "I
can't afford," I mean,
these are, you know?
Wine background helps, I get them,
I know which wines have a
little more alcohol than others
and I'm like, (laughter)
so when I get them
in a real place, after
four glasses of wine, when.
You know what pisses me off?
I go to conferences like this with them,
they sit with me on stage,
they spew their bullcrap,
because they wanna make money
on you, and then when
I get them drunk,
they're like, "Yeah,
you're telling the truth."
They can't be my friends,
I can only call them my acquaintances
or my contemporaries.
They can't be my friends
when they do that, right?
And, when I talk to them,
they're like, "Gary, I can't afford it,"
and they get real with me, these are guys
I've known for seven, 10
years, they get real with me,
they're like, "Gary, it's hard to go back,
"I came from nothing, now I got this."
And I look at it and I'm,
they have so much, you know?
One of 'em right now literally,
he vacations like 40% of his life,
he could vacation 20% of his life
and deploy the other 20% against building
an actual thing that has value
to the end consumer long-term.
My friends, we're at a very awkward place
in Internet culture, where
everybody's absolutely,
and it's just business culture,
it's not even Internet culture,
where everybody's absolutely thinking
way too short-term.
The scarier part is, this mobile shift
is happening very quickly,
and you're gonna wake
up in 36 to 48 months
and all that desktop
traffic is gonna be gone,
and you're gonna have to adjust,
and people's attentions are
gonna be in different places,
and you're gonna have to adjust.
And things are gonna come, listen,
I don't, listen, I like D.R. better
than branding, too.
I like math. I like knowing the math.
I love running Facebook ads
and running 80 bucks and getting
a customer for Wine Library for a buck 20,
and knowing that they're gonna shop.
Like, I love it!
It's just only part of it,
it can't be your business, right?
I don't like Snapchat,
Snapchat's hard! (laughter)
Snapchat is hard.
You have to create content.
It's television, it's
Youtube, it's way harder
than writing copy, or being good at
planning the creative and the planning
the segmentation and cohorts and math.
Math is commoditized,
brand is not.
And that's just true, it's true,
there was no math that got me
to buy these Nikes.
Nike's brand got me to buy these Nikes.
Got it?
And, there's so many smart ways to do it.
How many people here have done
campaigns using Instagram
influencers for their business?
Raise your hand.
Jesus. (laughter)
I would tell you besides Facebook,
the best math arbitrage in the world
is Instagram influencers product
placement and conversion.
Yet, because, you know why I asked it?
Because I know that it's
not pure math, right?
It's not pure, there's an ad platform,
and I can just do it,
there's no algorithm, there's no exchange,
there's no affiliate, there's no that,
because there's some other thing
besides that, where you gotta reach out
to a person, negotiate, something.
And you gotta think
about the creative,
and how the brand
looks on the picture,
because there's something,
99.6% of this room is not involved.
Even though mathematically,
it's so easy to track,
because they run it,
they do a call to action with a code,
or they put a link in their profile
and you can quantifiably, not qual, quant.
Not qual, quant!
Yet, because there's
just 10% of something
that isn't horsecrap, man,
I'm really fighting here.
(heartily laughter)
Because there's only 10% of something
that's not algorithmically,
sit in your shorts,
not talk to another human,
run all math,
this entire room has
stayed away from it.
While in March 2013
it's the second best
quant conversion
on the Internet.
SHREDZ and Protein World have gone
from zero to
50 and 80 million dollars
in sales in 24 months,
product placing their crap
on pretty girls on Instagram.
Where are you guys?
I'll tell you where you are,
you're in the cliche place,
that makes the next five years
not look so good,
that's where you are!
So, I come here
to be Debbie Downer
for a few minutes, (laughter)
only out of love, only
out of hope (loud claps)
that three to nine people in here
listen to me hardcore and do (laughter).
And I'm, by the way, I mean it!
I've done this a long time.
I see a lot of faces I've
known for a long time,
I've done this a long time.
I know that I can come in here
and do my thing,
and everybody feels it
and bunch of, I mean,
I'm watching your faces,
that's why I'm glad the lights are on,
I'm seeing what's going on,
people are commenting about people
that are doing the Snapchat thing,
and who's doing it, so
it's like, I'm watching.
And people get inspired, and
people get somewhat curious,
they may go home and go
down the rabbit hole,
they're thinking about
other people in here
that they know that
were kinda selling this,
and they're like, "Oh, wait a minute,
"maybe I should go talk
to Rick one more time."
I know what's going on.
And then, this is what happens.
Next Thursday happens,
and next Thursday
you're quant game
didn't look so good,
you made a little bit
less than you thought you
were supposed to, one of
your goddamn affiliates
dropped out, and your
moneys don't look so good
and you go on the defense, and go back
to tried and true, instead of the offense.
And you look that wave of innovation
in the face, and it's over there,
and you look at it with complete
and utter disrespect as it comes
marching directly for your mouth.
And so, I'm looking for
three to nine people,
the three to nine people that I get
every four or five years, that say,
"Gary, I saw you at
South by Southwest 2011,
"I was one of those copyrighter jerkoffs,
"conversion, this, that, the other thing.
"I was making 800,000 a year selling pills
"from China that I white-labelled,
"I had no idea what is in it. (laughter)
"I bet you I killed thousands of people.
"And then you spoke to me,
you spoke to me
"that day, and you changed my life.
"I was some $480 e-books
that all it was
"was crap I got for free
around the Internet,
"and you spoke to me,
and you changed me."
That's who I'm looking for today.
Three to nine of you, (audience cheers),
that are willing to be patient
to be proud about when your kids
look your name up on the Internet
in 30 years, and realize
you did it the right way,
instead of the wrong way.
(audience applauds and cheers)
And you know what
the best part is for me?
And I want to go
into Q and A now,
so, listen, I've clearly set the tone
for a direction of a
talk, they've got runners,
please go practical with me, right?
Let's go into Q and A and like,
please go practical, like
this transactional thing,
I'll answer any social
one-on-one on this.
I highly recommend you
don't leave, at all,
that's a humongous mistake,
you're leaving a lot
of money on the table,
but do your thing. (laughter)
But I will say this, I will say this,
the best part for me
about this whole talk
is I'm gonna be historically correct
about what I just said,
this will get replayed and regurgitated
and I'm gonna feel really good.
It feels fun for me when
I got made fun of
that Facebook would
never age up in 2007. Right?
When I said the grandma
thing is gonna happen,
I said, kids are gonna get older,
they're gonna have kids,
they're gonna put pictures
on there, and the grandma
is gonna wanna see the pictures
and they're gonna start using it.
It's fun for me to
stand here and tell you,
you will all be on
Snapchat in 36 months
and you're like, "No way, man."
Cool, see you in 36
months, Rick! (laughter)
And so, (laughter)
and so, that's fun for me,
and so, I don't want this talk to just
be fun for me. I want it to
bring value for some of you.
So, listen, it's not easy to go back,
it's not easy to invest.
You know what really pisses me off,
mainly on the collective?
Is people just don't
wanna put in the work.
Like, you can keep all the vulnerable
or bullcrap money that
you're making right now
in parallel to learning this thing
that I'm telling you, by just working
four more hours a day,
instead of, you know?
I don't know,
maybe you shouldn't rent
expenive cars for the day,
so you can take
an Instagram photo
and tell the world
what kind of pimp
entrepreneur you are.
(laughter)
Jesus!
Maybe that, right?
Maybe that would be
a good goddamn idea?
(audience cheers)
(chuckles)
Thank you.
(audience cheers)
- [Voiceover] Alright.
- [Gary] Thank you.
Thank you.
(loud techno music)
Alright, we got a lot of time.
We got a lot of time for Q and A
and then I also pushed back
a bunch of calls, so I think
I'm gonna do a little bit of a
book signing afterwards, too.
(audience cheers) Not sure, so.
And some selfies would be cool.
Alright.
- [Voiceover] Hi, Gary.
- Where you at?
- [Voiceover] Right here,
right here, right here.
- Alright homie, what's your name?
- [Voiceover] Howard Partridge.
- Howard, how are you?
- [Voiceover] I am
phenomenal, how are you?
- Super great!
- Alright.
So you said that VR is the future,
don't humans long for flesh
to flesh, true community, and if so,
how will those two coexist,
in your opinion, in the future?
- I think humans do.
I think that when
your brains get tricked,
funny things happen,
so I think, you know?
When testosterone
and other chemicals
get lifted, you know?
Look, there's a bunch of dudes in here
that know when their chemicals shift,
they become different versions
of themeselves, right?
So, I will tell you that, yes,
and we're not gonna all live in pods
and not interact with each other,
but I would tell you right now,
and I'm, don't forget,
I'm talking 20 years
from now, I think we're seeing
the early stages now, but I'm completely
convinced we're gonna
spend an enormous amount
of time, maybe not in our homes,
like, I'm actually, it's funny,
I'm trying to think about like,
should I invest in real estate
and convert 'em into resorts that?
I'm tryin' to figure it out, because
there's gonna be some
amazing businesses built
on the back of this new world
where you can have your.
I mean, bro, Howard, what if we all
literally felt we were right,
what if this all felt real,
and we were just not here?
I mean, I know, I get it,
I get it, but I'm telling you,
sit here in 1988, let me be somebody
that told you about the Internet in 2016,
and they would never believe you.
Do you know how fast (snaps
fingers) things happen?
Internet dating was weird and taboo
seven years ago, now it is weird
and taboo to not Internet date.
Shit changes fast!
(laughter)
You're welcome.
Oh, we got a, we going this?
- [Voiceover] Hey, Gary.
- Hey, brother.
- First of all, when I first heard
your story, I thought you were 22, so.
- [Gary] Thanks. (laughs)
- I'm so glad you're 38. (laughs)
- [Gary] I'm 40, goddamn it!
(laughter)
- I'm 44, I've been-
- [Gary] You look good, bro.
- My leads, thank you.
- [Gary] What's your name?
- My name is Mitch.
Chervis.
- [Gary] Mitch, awesome.
- [Mitch] Thanks.
(laughs) Thanks, you know my name,
I don't know what I said this for.
(laughter) Sorry.
I go from business to business,
I get my leads, they send me work,
I have an auto glass
company here in the valley.
I don't do anything on the Internet.
- [Gary] Okay, that's a mistake.
- Yeah, it's huge, right?
- [Gary] This internet things
got a chance!
- [Mitch] But I, and
I know it, it's I know
it's coming, but I don't know how,
like, I don't wanna be,
you ever watch The Office,
and there's like Bob Vance from Vance
Refrigeration.
- [Gary] I don't watch TV.
Ever!
- [Mitch] There's Bob Vance,
Vance Refrigeration, every time
he introduces himself, he's Bob Vance,
Vance Refrigeration.
I don't wanna be Mitch,
I'm on the Burton Auto Glass,
like, I don't wanna be that.
- [Gary] Got it!
- [Mitch] But can you,
can you have your
personal life on Facebook,
and your business life?
Can you have your personal Snapchat
and your business Snapchat,
and your personal Instagram?
- [Gary] Yep!
- [Mitch] Is it authentic?
- [Gary] Sure!
- Like, can my business,
I wanna be like (laughter),
I don't know what they
call, you know what I mean?
Yes, that's the answer.
- [Gary] I think I know
what you mean, but I think
it's so ludicrous that all
I could give you is, sure!
- (laughs) It seems inauthentic to me,
because I'm authentic with my guys
that I go and get my business with now,
I'm authentic with them, and we sit
and we chat and I--
- [Gary] Can I ask you a question, Mitch?
- Yeah.
- Do you text other human beings?
- [Mitch] I do, all the time.
- Are you a fake, weird person
when you text?
- [Mitch] No.
- Okay, good.
So do that on the Internet
and business. (laughter)
Like it's a, your mind, you decided
to put your brain in a situation
that makes you believe that.
- [Mitch] Yeah.
It's hard to--
- Everything's hard, Mitch!
- I know, (laughter)
like I don't wanna like,
I don't wanna ruin my
personal relationships,
I have personal relationships--
- Oh, well Mitch, don't
sell your best friend
on your service!
Mitch, do you go to
your best friend's house
every day and go, "Hey
bro, buy some glass!"
- Yeah, I don't.
I almost do the opposite,
I know what you're saying,
because I do shy away from my,
everybody says, "Oh,
go get your warm leads,
"go at your family, go
at your friends first,
"and then you'll go out
and get your thing."
But what you're saying is--
- [Gary] Mitch, those are
people that just sell advice
and never build an
actual goddamn business!
(audience cheers and applauds)
Mitch.
- [Mitch] It's true.
- [Gary] You built a business,
everything I do online is how I did it
20 years in real life.
I never try to
close on a first date,
I wrote a book called,
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right-Hook,
which was give, give,
give, and then ask,
not take, ask.
So, just be a nice human there.
As a matter of fact,
if you really understood
what I did with Wine Library TV,
I educated people on it.
Why don't you educate people
on your genre, put out
that content, whether they.
You know how many people bought wine
because of my videos, not for me?
Let me give you the
answer, most. (laughter)
Because I was looking
to build a brand,
not a transaction,
so you can go
and educate people on.
Do you feel like your competitors
or other people in the marketplace
are selling less quality stuff,
bad advice and other things?
- Absolutely!
- [Gary] Then teach America,
Mitch! (audience cheers)
- Thank you.
- That feels good, right?
That feels authentic?
- [Mitch] Yeah, yeah.
- You don't feel like a scum bucket
doin' that, do you Mitch?
- [Mitch] No I don't.
- No, okay!
(Mitch laughs)
So do that!
- [Mitch] Thank you.
- You don't all of a
sudden go on the Internet
and turn into something like jerkoff.
- [Mitch] That's what I
feel like, I'm gonna go
on there be like, "Hey, everybody,
"love Auto Glass!"
I can just be yourself.
- [Gary] This is what
everybody's confused about with money
and fame and notoriety, like,
I get credit now, like,
"Oh, Gary, you're so nice."
I'm like, what?
Money and fame or notoriety
doesn't change you, it just exposes you.
The Internet's not
gonna change you, Mitch,
it's just gonna expose
how awesome you are!
- [Mitch] Thank you.
(audience applauds and cheers)
- Where are we goin'?
- Right over here.
(laughter)
Hey, Gary, I'm Matt, I'm a long-time--
- Matt, your crew is hyped,
you guys feel. (audience
cheers and screams)
You guys feel like
you're good people,
(Matt laughs) you're gonna be the ones,
I've been watching your vibe
on this talk.
- [Matt] We're the brands man,
we're the brands.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Matt] So, my name's Matt,
I'm a long-time lurker,
but now I've seen every
single #AskGaryVee Show,
DailyVee, I'm lovin' it.
- [Gary] Thank you, bro.
- We run, my wife and I--
- So wait a minute, let's
break this down for a second.
- [Matt] Yeah man.
- You mean you've
consumed all this content,
for free, I very often say on the show
please leave one comment,
it's my oxygen, and you've decided
to never, (laughter) you didn't pay,
and you never, ever wanted to leave
one comment?
- No, no, not at all.
So, when I started watching.
(laughter)
When I started watching you,
I was 50 episodes in, is
when I heard about you,
so I watched all 50 episodes
and then, I remember it being,
it was like 57 or something,
and you were like, you
started it by going,
"We got a lot of lurkers here,
"you guys need to leave a comment."
And that was the first show I
left a comment on. (loud clap)
- [Gary] Alright bro, good, thank you!
- And then, from then
on, when an episode
spoke to me, I left a
comment, I shared it--
- Respect, meritocracy!
Don't give it to me if I don't deserve it.
- [Matt] Yeah, man.
- Alright.
- Okay, so, my wife and I, we run
an online school for
wedding photographers,
we are wedding photographers,
we're educators, as is
our whole crew here,
so, my question is, we've built it
to a spot that we're really comfortable
with right now, but we can either
keep it niched down and build it more,
with that, our audience, which is
a money audience in the
scheme of everybody.
Or, we can use the framework
we've build, the system
we've built online,
rebrand it, repackage
it for another industry,
who can I meet some
of you guys out there
who need education
in other industries.
What do I do, do I go still with the niche
or do I build bigger, now
that I've got a system?
- It's a personal
question, but the answer's
both can work, I think, if you go
into other genres, you need to make
sure you spend it an
ungodly amount of time
vetting who your partner is
around their expertise,
because what people
normally do in this moment,
is there's so excited
about going wide,
that the first person, they like,
they back to like
being romantic about it,
like, "Oh, John's a good enough guy
"and seems like he knows
enough about pastries,
"good, he's our pastry guy." Right?
So, I would tell you,
if you wanna feel good,
and you wanna do the right thing,
that you spend an enormous amount of time
on vetting people in, and
then, more importantly,
and this is back to hiring and firing,
people are always crippled by hiring,
I'll hire anybody.
You could even walk into my office
with a Patriots jersey,
and I'll still hire you.
(laughter)
Yep!
True.
But, 'cause it's not about hiring,
it's about firing, right?
- [Matt] Yeah.
- [Gary] So, after you made a gut call,
Rick's the best tire guy you ever met,
he's gonna be in the tire genre,
then you watch, and if you don't like
how Rick goes, and this is where everybody
goes to the dark side, Rick becomes
the best salesperson.
You know, 'cause Rick's getting
a little black hat, right?
Converting a little of this,
and he's your biggest
earner, by percentage,
'cause you're making a vig on Rick,
'cause he's on your platform,
and that's when you, even though
Rick's the number one person,
if he's doin' the wrong thing,
you've got to cut him.
And that's the part that nobody does.
- [Matt] Yeah.
- Nobody devalues currency over legacy.
- And unfortunately, that's most.
- Yeah.
Which is, I mean, I'm glad you said it,
'cause that's exactly why we chose
the people that are sitting here
to be our educators
in our first academy,
because they're people
that we've known
for a long time, we know--
- [Gary] Of course, that's
the easiest thing to vet.
- [Matt] Yeah,
and, they're the best.
So, how would I actually reach out
to people in industries
that I am not an expert in
and find those people who
should be the educators in that?
- [Gary] It's called work,
so what you'll do (laughter).
- I'm ready for that!
- Yeah, I'm sure, you did it,
I mean, that's what's so great
about today's world, right?
You can literally type in into Google
any subject matter, see the first
three pages results, click 'em,
lists, go on Twitter, see how they roll,
you can watch
them from afar, you know?
Since you've been watching as much
of my content, I'm sure you know,
I mean, I feel very confident right now
that you'll know how to
sniff out certain things.
Just put in the work.
What I would do if I were you
is to try to think about the marketplace
that is either the hottest,
or the most profitable,
like, make a business
decision on which
sector you go into next.
i also think, a compliment
to your core thing
is smart, so whether that's catering
or filming or I just, I don't know,
I would think about that, too.
- [Matt] Yeah.
- Cool.
- [Matt] So when it's marketing,
and we give you a call,
and say, we vetted we for quite awhile.
- Yes.
- [Matt] My name's Matt Kennedy.
Done. (laughter)
Thank you brother.
Appreciate it man.
Who's next?
- [Voiceover] Straight in
front of you, in the back.
- Let's go to.
Oh, I get to pick?
Oh, this is fun.
Okay. (laughter)
Hello.
- [Voiceover] Hi.
- [Gary] How are you?
- I'm good.
- [Gary] Good, could you
put your mic to your mouth?
- Okay.
- [Garry] Awesome, what's your name?
- Terry.
- [Garry] Terry.
- I didn't, I've never followed you, so,
I apologize.
- [Gary] Huge mistake, Terry!
Huge! (laughter)
But I knew it, I could, I knew that's
what you were gonna say.
- [Terry] I subscribed
to your channel.
- [Gary] Thank you so much!
(laughter)
- Okay, my question is,
you were talking is,
I know that everything's mobile.
- [Gary] Yes!
- So why are we developing websites?
- Well, because mobile devices deliver
us websites, darlin'.
- [Terry] No, but I
mean, on the big screen.
- Well, we shouldn't.
When we design our websites today,
anybody in here who's
when they're designing
the UI and the UX, as it's called,
should be designing
for a mobile device,
not for a laptop.
- 'Cause I've seen lots of money spent
on beautiful designs--
- [Gary] That's right!
- That show great on a web page.
- That's right, those are
people that are not as good
at business.
(laughter)
It's just true.
- [Terry] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Cool.
Number three, let's do it.
- Hey, Gary.
Matt Rickets, I've seen you at
several live events this year,
I was at Thrive, that
was a pretty good one.
I love that you customize the message
for each audience.
- [Gary] Appreciate it man.
- [Matt] Very different kinda
vibe tonight than Thrive
and Digital Marketer
at their event, so.
- It's mainly, I basically
have a good speaking career
because I really give a
crap about you, right?
It's literally you, right?
Like, there's people, how many people
have seen me more than once this year?
- [Voiceover] Wooh!
- Right, so I'm scared of that.
I'm scared of that, right?
Because most of my
friends and contemporaries
have the same slides, it's the same talk,
and so, I have no interest in you looking
at your phone while I'm on stage,
so that's why I do it.
- Yeah, so, what I wanna do
is ask you a tactical question (mumbles).
- [Gary] Sure.
- Facebook, you talked about.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Using it extensively in my business,
it's unusual in the
house cleaning industry.
- [Gary] House cleaning, okay.
- Not many people are marketing well.
- [Gary] Yes!
- But are you using the new lead ads
from Facebook effectively,
or are you still taking
them off-site to capture leads?
Are you doing it right in the--
- Both!
I actually think the phone call ads
are really incredible.
- [Matt] Okay.
- 'Cause people are mobile devices
and just press the phone number.
And the phone is an amazing closer.
I test everything, man.
I'm day trading attention, so what I,
by the way, when somebody watch,
hey, whoever's watching this,
when you watch this in six months,
whatever my answer
is now may change.
I'm changing my, this used to drive
my poor dad crazy.
My dad's a real (spits
loudly) word his bond,
stick forever, so like,
when I would change
my decisions, he'd be
like, "But you said,"
I'm like, yeah, but I changed my mind,
he'd be like, "What the?"
He would be so pissed.
(laughter)
So, I'm using them all, depends
on the, but remember,
let's take it step back
for everybody, creative is
the variable of success,
the words and the pictures and the video
will impact the success.
So, we could talk about the functionality,
is it a click out to a website?
Is it a, within it's lead
gen, is it a phone number?
But if the creative isn't good,
so, the reason I start with
day trading attention is,
Facebook's attention is still underpriced,
even though it's more expensive
than it was 24 months ago, mainly because
a room like this is still
not spending enough on it.
And corporate America,
forget those losers, right?
So, you start there, but then there's
a whole 'nother conversation,
it's why I wrote Jab,
Jab, Jab, Right-Hook,
because I was like,
look, this is important.
So, I would tell you,
first, need to try 30
to 50, 100 different variables,
different times, different
cadences, different,
before you say.
You know how many people here,
you know how many people here
poo-pooed Facebook ads after spending
their first thousand
or $10,000 on Facebook?
Losing players, bro.
- And then one last thing.
Do you still anticipate putting out
that evergreen product
for small businesses
or is that more of a long-term plan?
- [Gary] You mean the VaynerMedia side?
- Yeah, we talked a little bit about that.
- He's referring to, I'm,
it's weird you said that,
I was thinking about it
most of the flight here today.
I'm fascinated that my
brand is much stronger
in rooms like this than
it is corporate America.
I built VaynerMedia
from zero to 100 million
in four years, in revenue, in an industry
that didn't even know who I was,
or liked me or buy
what I want or has no.
Like, this, so, when I think about
where am I leaving a billion dollars
potentially on the table it's building
a SaaS product
around my core strength
for businesses of this nature.
So, I think about it a lot. (laughs)
I just, I'm pretty intuitive
and I do things when I
feel like they're ready
but it's on my mind.
Because I know I can win,
I know that I can get $60,000
out of every person here,
and bring them back more.
I just haven't put
it all together yet,
because I won't launch it,
even at the height of
my career right now,
separated myself from the
other social media people
would be really easy for me to convert,
I care so much about lifetime value
and legacy, that until
the final little piece
clicks in my head
where I know even
the worst practitioners in here
will feel good about the
investment they made on it,
I'm just not there yet.
Four!
- [Voiceover] Hi, Gary, thanks--
- I'm super into this. (chuckles)
(audience laughter)
Four!
What's up bro?
- First of all, thanks
so much for all you do.
- [Gary] What's your name?
- Jared.
- [Gary] Jared, thanks man.
- So, I currently use Facebook,
Twitter, a little bit of Youtube
and Periscope for one
of my businesses and--
- [Gary] What kind of business?
- I'm a physical therapy
private practice owner,
and.
- [Voiceover] Yeah!
- Thank you. (laughter)
And I--
- [Gary] People love to be heard, wooo!
- I also teach, I have an
online business teaching
about private practice.
And so, my question is,
that I'm already feeling really stretched
just to do those four platforms--
- [Gary] Makes sense.
- Especially in the way that
you advised to have content,
native for each platform.
- [Gary] Yes, yep.
- So, my question is--
- [Gary] What do you do about
it, right? Deep or wide, right?
- [Jared] Exactly, do I go deeper--
- So, here's my first question,
how many hours a day are you working?
- 10 or 12.
- [Gary] Are you pumped
where you are financially,
like are you at a spot where you're good,
you're happy, like, you're good?
- I'm happy, but I want more.
- [Gary] Good, so work 12 to 14.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] That's the answer, bro.
- Can I ask one follow-up though,
in terms of--
- [Gary] Sure!
- Do you feel like
it's more important
to put that extra time
into the platforms
I'm already on, or do you feel
that Instagram and Snapchat
are so important now
and moving forward
that I need to add those in?
- [Gary] It'a good question.
It's a good question, it's
the right follow-up question,
so good job.
I would look at the conversion,
I would look at your business,
and if I felt like there is a moment
where if Twitter doesn't
bring enough revenue in,
and it's disproportionate
to the amount of time
that you're spending on it
that you can jump off.
I've jumped off Tumblr and Google+, right?
They became a time,
so, yeah, there is a time,
but, I still want you to work more,
if you're not content, you know?
Content is content, you know?
Like, either you want more or you don't.
Like, it's a binary game, like, and so,
you have to give up other things
and deploy more of this,
if you want more, or maybe
and there's nothing wrong with that,
as a matter of fact, I,
this is not a joke, and a lot of people
would not believe this,
if there was a drug that I could take
and there probably is, but I'm
scared of drugs (laughter),
but, if there was,
yeah, maybe a shot,
I'm scared of those, too.
But, I wouldn't mind to take
some ambition out of my body.
I wouldn't. You know?
I wouldn't mind to have a
little more work-life balance,
you know what I mean?
Like so, but, extra time
fixes all vulnerabilities.
Cool.
One.
- [Voiceover] Gary.
- Yes.
- [Voiceover] Thank you, man.
- You're welcome, bro.
- I got three questions for you,
first one is,
- [Gary] What's your name?
- [Man] Which wine
pairs best with fish?
- [Gary] Fish?
(laughter)
- [Man] That's first question.
- [Gary] Spanish White Riojas.
- Okay, perfect.
- [Gary] Good.
- [Man] I'll make a note of that,
said on Facebook last night
I was gonna ask that question today.
Second--
- [Gary] Way to come through, bro!
- Yeah. (laughs)
Second question is,
my partner and I
are here from
Calgary, Alberta, Canada.
- [Gary] Love it.
- We operate a real
estate brokerage there,
we're realtors, obviously,
(audience cheers)
I'm very interested (Gary
chuckles) in Snapchat,
been on the platform for about
a year or so, just really started
digging into it within the
last probably couple of months
since you got on there and told everybody
to get onto Snapchat.
(Gary laughs)
I'm comfortable with video,
I've been doing video since 2010,
big inspiration for me
getting on to Youtube,
starting a video blog, that sort of thing.
- [Gary] Yep.
- I'm curious, what kind of content
should we be putting out there
(Gary sighs) in terms of Snapchat
15, 20 seconds--
- [Gary] Are you only selling,
are you in renting spaces?
- [Man] So we do property management,
we have a mortgage brokerage,
we also have a
real estate sales division.
- So, look you got a
map the demo right now,
right now Snapchat in Canada
is skewing very young.
So, one, you're investing,
right, you're investing.
You know, are you guys
able to do transactions
with the 20 to 35-year-old demo a lot?
- Sure, yeah, probably pushing
more towards the
35-year-old demo, for sure.
- So you're probably, my intuition
is you're 24 to 30 months away,
which is a long time,
from like it getting really good.
- [Man] Yeah, but I love what you say
about investing into the platform.
- But you gotta be practical
with your investment, right?
- [Man] Sure.
- [Gary] And so, I would tell you,
are you hardcore Facebook?
- Hard work, we run a lot
of Facebook advertising.
- [Gary] How's it going?
- Really well, actually.
Really well.
- [Gary] It probably can go better.
- Okay.
- So I would tell you, take 50%
of what you were
gonna do with Snapchat,
and deploy that to
be better at Facebook.
But still do Snapchat.
- [Man] We're also on Instagram, as well,
we just started diving into it
about three weeks ago,
four weeks ago we've, we grown--
- [Gary] So, seems like you
been around for a little while,
you remember my favorite concept
around real estate, right,
which is own the story around the town?
- Right.
- [Gary] Quadruple down on that.
- Okay.
- Most of you guys, like you,
2010 Crush It! blueprint, do this,
most of you have
not gone far enough
at owning the
review of every business
and park and store in your area,
and the three to five I can think of
that have, have destroyed it.
- [Man] Right.
- So.
- [Man] Okay, last question.
- Yeah.
- [Man] Can I get a snap?
- [Man] Chat selfie?
- Yes!
- [Man] With you?
- [Man] Cool.
- Cool.
(audience applauds)
Let's go to two.
Oh my god, three's beard is amazing!
I'm gonna save it, I'm gonna save it.
- Thanks, brother.
(man from audience shouts unintelligibly)
(laughter)
- Now, now,
how many people here on Snapchat?
(audience cheers)
So, please take a picture,
I'm gonna do a contest with you guys,
there's a filter, did you see this?
- Oh, cool!
- [Gary] I made a custom
Geo-filter, for this talk only,
there it is.
- Awesome!
- How sick is that?
- Thank you, brother!
- You got it, bro! (loud snap)
(audience cheers)
Weird high-fives are weird.
(laughter)
Hello.
- Hi, I'm Frances.
- [Gary] How are you?
- I'm fine.
- [Gary] Good!
- How would you recommend using Periscope?
- Well, very carefully, for most people,
'cause live video is really hard.
And so, I would tell you that,
as I've been auditing
the live video space,
it's been, I would really,
one guy's point of view
is subjective, clearly,
but I think 95 to 97% of
the content is disastrous.
It's super hard.
So, first and foremost, I would say,
do you feel like you can bring value
to the other person on the other end,
instead of just checking the box
that you're doing live video?
Is the first religious thing
that everybody has to decide.
After that, I would replicate
what's doing well in
live video on television.
So, I mean, I'm telling you right now,
I think, this is random,
if you like love, like skateboarding
or like basketball, or like hockey
or street hockey, I think somebody
can build a fairly big business
where they can make like a 100,000 a year
in a sponsor pretty fast,
if they're the livestream of like
the games that are going
on in their neighborhood.
So, think about sports, think about QVC,
I'm stunned.
I would tell you my biggest regret
is that I'm not still
doing Wine Library TV,
'cause I would be crushing
24-hour QVC Wine Library TV right now,
I'd be selling a crapload of wine.
So, replicate what did well on live
and television, variety shows,
sports, that, or telemarketing,
telethons, and just information.
But, too many people just wanna be live,
and say they're doing it,
and not realizing that almost
all their content is
just in their personal
best vested in interest.
I mean, you go look
at some of the people
right now that
are Periscope experts,
they go on Periscope,
and they're trying
to sell you the Periscope class.
Guys, can we just once and for all
have a real discussion that we have
to become dramatically more cynical
of people that are selling people
on themselves, when they've never
built a business in their lives,
outside of selling people?
(audience cheers and applauds)
Just a little bit, just a little bit.
So that's what I would do.
- So, how would you recommend using
Periscope in health and wellness?
- Content, right?
So if you can teach people,
if you can create a scheduled class
where it's always eight
to nine in the morning,
where you're gonna teach them yoga
or things of that nature,
and you set it up, something.
If you start with bringing
them value, you will win.
Most people don't wanna give anybody
the real value, 'cause they want them
to pay them for the real value,
which by the way,
with people like that,
is 97% of the time
crap to begin with.
And so, give your best
advice away to the world
in a structured, scheduled way,
build an audience, you'll
make much more money
with a yoga pants company,
buying advertising on you,
than charging everybody for the $29 e-book
to how to be a yoga
instructor on Periscope.
Brand over transaction.
Cool, one, no, I'm
sorry, three, the beard.
- [Man] Thanks, Gary,
I'm a huge fan.
Actually, I need you to sign my book.
I just watched you (Gary laughs)
present at Venture Madness.
- [Gary] I'm sorry, brother?
- I just watched you
present at Venture Madness,
like an hour or two ago.
- [Gary] Yes, we were there.
- Due to my beard, I'm
one of the cofounders
of the Dollar Beard Club,
don't know if you heard of it.
We spent bunch of money
on Facebook and Instagram,
I heard a statistic, and
I don't know if it's true
but they say over 65% of all mobile videos
they are watched without sound?
- Yes, that is true.
That's why VaynerMedia is got a huge
transcribing and kind of like,
what else do they call it?
Captioning division brewing right now
for all of our social videos.
It's crazy.
There's also a data point that I'm trying
to confirm of how much people
are watching like three,
four, five, six, seven, eight
minute videos, all with captioning and,
it's unbelievable.
So the answer is yes,
that is an emerging thing.
- [Man With Beard] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Come in here, I'll sign it real fast.
This way you won't have
to stand in a huge line.
You had courage and ask a question.
Two!
And I'll go, I'll just keep going,
I feel like I'm out of bounds.
- [Voiceover] How's it going, Gary?
- So well it would blow your face off.
- Good.
(laughter)
So, just throwin' it back to
our homie's virtual reality question.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Do you see virtual reality going towards
more gaming or reliving an experience
or being able to live an
experience with someone else,
like a family member, while
they're on a trip or something?
- Oh, you get a pen?
Yes!
- [Man] To both?
- All of 'em. (laughter)
- [Man] Perfect.
- Right?
Entertainment, porn's gonna be first,
'cause they're always fast, right?
So, porn will be huge,
I'm super pumped.
(laughter)
(loud clapping)
I mean.
Is that my timer or was
that, I said something weird?
(laughter)
I hope it's my timer.
But porn, movies, video games,
like imagine Madden 2026 and you really
feel like you're the
quarterback, and it's cool.
So, but everything,
there's companies
already now that are filming
people's lives, so they can relive them,
so you can literally
relive holding your baby
for the first time, and feel it, 98.6%.
Like there's gonna be, guys,
tourism's vulnerable.
Like, what if you really
felt like right now,
you put on your contacts
and you feel like you're
at the Eiffel Tower?
Like you really felt it?
So, the whole world will be disrupted,
just like the whole world
was disrupted when the railroad came.
Guys, history, history,
like Detroit and Pittsburgh and the ports,
when the innovation of a, you know, boats?
That was the innvovation!
Holy crap, there's this
thing that can do this?
And the ports became rich!
And then railroads, oh
crap, that's different!
Like, and then suburbs, boxed stores
and Walmart made their bank, right?
And then the Internet, Amazon,
like, guys, the world will always do this
and you will always sit here and be like,
"No, it's gonna be exactly like this
"for the rest of time 'cause I'm happy
"with the way it is."
(laughter)
So, yeah, I think all of those things.
- [Man] Awesome.
- And to answer it more
interestingly for you, without hyperbole,
it will be the talented entrepreneurs
that decide which
genres they go into
that will disrupt it.
Taxi cabs didn't have
to be the next thing
that went, it was just
that Garrett Camp
and Travis Kalanick
decided it was.
Got it?
So, I don't know if it's gonna
be entertainment or sports
or reliving things, it's gonna
be the best entrepreneurs producing
for that platform first, you know?
Jeff Bezos decided
bookstores were in trouble,
he could've decided wine stores
were in trouble, you know?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Got it?
- [Man] Thanks.
- Yeah.
Four, I know I'm off the time,
but I'm eating to my own book signing
so I'm gonna go a little further.
- [Kassem] Gary, my name is Kassem.
I appreciate you being here.
I think my question's
gonna get me yelled at
a little bit, I don't want you to--
- [Gary] Do you want that,
are into that weird crap?
- [Kassem] No.
I'm a glutton for punishment,
actually.
- [Gary] Okay, good.
- [Kassem] I know what
you're saying as far as
high integrity marketing,
principle center, provide value,
and I know you're kinda saying
stop putting things in a box,
and I'm gonna just--
- And by the way, I'm saying,
if you're 100% in that,
you should start debating
shifting some of it.
I'm not saying, hey give up your 15,
$150,000 a year arbitrage that's going
into your pocket and
you're sitting at home
and it's great and like, and then
just go become Mother
Teresa and close that down,
but I'm saying pay attention.
- [Kassem] Absolutely.
- Okay.
- [Kassem] Just, from a
philosophical perspective,
I love everything you're saying,
from a practical
application perspective,
like, if you were to write Gary's,
the 10 things that you need to do
on a day-to-day basis
to market like Gary,
'cause I hear the high level,
thought leadership
and building a brand,
but what's the, I mean,
walk me through the day-to-day.
Is that annoying?
- No, it's not annoying,
it's a great question.
I mean, I'm in a different
part of my career,
like, let's start with,
let's start with the
fact that because
I thought the social media
was gonna be important,
after running Wine Library from
three to 50 million dollars
in revenue in a heartbeat
(snaps fingers loudly),
I started, after eight
years, 96 straight months
of doubling revenue, 20%
revenue growth minimum,
every month that I operated the business.
The first month that I
started doing Twitter, right?
Our business was flat.
So I made a decision, on whatever
was going on in my life at the time,
that this future thing was so important,
that I was gonna spend
15 hours a day replying
to every person on Twitter,
and built brand. Right?
So, I can give you that practical,
'cause that happened, what I did was,
every day, I lost money,
to invest in my future.
And that's really
what I'm saying here
to everybody, right?
And so, if you're making money right now,
you gotta decide how you're
gonna make your money.
I didn't know how I
was gonna make my money
when I decided to build
some notoriety and attention.
At first, I thought I was gonna
be selling more wine, right?
Then I realized it was gonna
be investing in these things,
which made me a lot, a lot of money.
Then it was, holy crap,
they wanna pay
me $1,000,000
to write a book?
That's money!
Then it was, wait, you want
to pay me $80,000 to speak?
That was money.
Then it was, I'm gonna
build a business again,
'cause everybody thinks I'm Gary Vee,
and nobody remembered that I actually
built a business, and I don't wanna be
like all those other people,
so I'm gonna go back and
start another business.
So I decided to start a
client service business,
because I realized
brands were spending
all their money on TV
and banner retargeting
and email, and I knew
this social media thing
was gonna come.
So that day-to-day was,
me and my brother
and his four homies
out of college, like, cold
email the CMO of Campbells
and just start hustling
and got Gillette
to pay us $80,000
to do an activation in Las Vegas
with some Facebook stuff
that we didn't understand,
that they didn't understand,
and then I started hiring people
and getting more clients and putting
out content to lead to more business.
Like, I just, I built an agency, right?
So, it's not about building your brand
and then an arbitraging it,
it's about deciding what business
you want to run and figuring it out.
For example, I know that everybody
in this room, listen to this,
this is a good one, most people
in this room can make more money
than they're making by buying things
on Ebay and relisting them on Amazon.
(laughter)
(audience applauds)
It's a crazy arbitrage right now.
So, what I mean by that,
is that was a tactic, right?
Like, hey, you wanna make $100,000?
Go find two categories,
do the math over 40 days,
100 days, learn, put in work,
and pick any random category
and buy it on Ebay and
resell it on Amazon.
(loud lone whistle)
- [Kassem] Thanks, man.
- Yeah, man.
(laughs)
One.
And I think, what we did there,
which is, thanks brother, you got a pen?
You're welcome.
Who do I make it out to?
- [Voiceover] Kyle.
- You wanna take a picture?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- Get up here.
I'm cozy. (speaker is
far away from microphone)
Oh, you're just gonna take a weird
picture of me doin' it,
that's so weird? (laughter)
- And it's C-Y-L-E.
- C-Y?
Awesome.
Wish you well, man.
Good luck to you.
- [Cyle] Thanks, man.
I think I'm gonna meet you
at Andy, in Vegas,
- [Gary] Hope so, hope so.
Good to see you.
One,
(audience applauds)
- Hey, Gary, how you doin'?
- [Gary] Really well.
- Good.
I actually--
- [Gary] What's your name?
- My name is Michael.
- [Gary] Michael.
- I actually tweeted
about one of the things
doing at ICON was to be to get you to sign
my book, or sign a copy of your book
and you actually favorited it. (laughter)
So, now I have to do it.
- [Gary] Let's do it!
- Alright.
My quick question is, I follow a lot
when you're on Periscope.
- [Gary] Okay.
- And I just wanted you to know
I'm kind of in the
online seminar business,
what do you think of Blab?
Do you think--
- [Gary] I haven't used it yet
out of like an inside joke
with myself. (laughter)
I'm not even kidding.
So many people want
me to do it with them,
that I'm literally just
jerking myself off
and not doing it.
(laughter)
That's literally the truth.
Like, I'm on a random kick of like,
I think it's funny.
And I don't wanna do it.
(laughter)
But meaning on the flip side,
back to everything you've heard from me,
I'm watching it every day.
Like, I'm watching Blab,
and I'm watching Peach,
and I'm watching
everything, everyday.
Blab isn't at a place
where my little inside joke
is more valuable for me to go,
like, the second I decide
Blab's valuable enough,
I'll get off my little joke.
- Do you, well, quick follow-up,
do you think that will kinda replace
or actually compete with like the,
all the webinar software that is, like--
- All that stuff.
I don't know, I don't know.
I mean, look, I do think
that online courses
and that stuff is a big business,
there's a lot of players,
Chase Jarvis has got his thing,
Udemy, Skillshare, there's a lot,
a lot players, everybody wants to do it,
they all want to do the same thing,
which is, they wanna build a platform,
sit in the middle, let you do your thing,
let me do my thing, take a percentage
of our action, way too much.
And that's what they're doing.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
I think that's a race to the bottom.
I think the person that wins it,
charges people very, very, very little,
everybody goes there and they win
because the platform shouldn't
make as much of the
vig for the providers
of the content who have the audience.
Are you gonna come up here
and get your book signed?
Let's do it.
Alright, four.
See, I blabbed you!
You wanted it so bad, I wanted
you to wait a little bit.
We're coming, though.
Hi.
Well, what is this, two for one gig?
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] Can I?
- Yes.
Sure.
- [Woman] For my husband,
T-E-E-R-R-Y.
- T-E?
- T-E-R-R-Y.
- Mhmmm, Terry.
- Yes, he's a big fan of you.
- Well, tell Terry I'm very happy.
- Yes, can I get a picture with you?
- Yes.
With you?
- Yeah!
- Get on here.
(laughs)
Sorry guys, I can listen to the question.
- Gary, Kerwin Rae from Australia,
mate, how are you?
- [Gary] Hey, brother, how are you?
- Good to see you again.
- [Gary] Yeah, thanks for
having me in Vegas that time.
- Mate, it was a pleasure.
It's really changed the
face of the way
that we do business--
- [Gary] Meaning, meaning?
You're welcome darling.
- [Kerwin] Meaning,
I'll give you some context.
Over Christmas, I started to realize
that we are socially illiterate
when it comes to promoting
or cross arrange
different social channels.
And so I came back from
my little bit of a break
with a vengeance, and we're now,
I have a videographer that's
following me basically
four days a week, we're
constantly filming content,
preparing it to push it out
across a whole range of channels.
Snapchat specifically
and just to give you
some gratitude for that,
in the first 10 days
of being on Snapchat,
we actually netted about
$11,000 in sales from--
- [Gary] Let me hear that one more time.
- In our first 10 days
of being on Snapchat
we netted about $11,000 in
sales. (audience cheers)
- Let me just help everybody
understand what that is,
that's called ROI, motherfuckers!
(audience cheers)
Seriously, guys, guys,
everything you do, and
the market looks for,
that's called direct mail.
It's been around forever,
it's transactional,
you send 40,000 of 'em to the mail,
you collect 18,000 coupons or 800 coupons,
you run the quant.
There's another thing,
it was called television,
it's how the biggest businesses
in the world were built,
it wasn't quantifiable, it
was just scale and brand.
Digital came along
and everybody decided
that the better bet was direct mail
because you could measure it,
and they wanted to punt television,
'cause you couldn't.
Got it?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- Cool, keep going.
- So that 11 grand came from
no direct promotion whatsoever,
just from snapbacks--
- [Gary] Oh, weird,
when you actually bring value,
people are like, "Oh, this feels better
"than the douchery that
everybody else is doing."
(laughter)
Weird!
Crazy, crazy.
- Which would happen while I just
leaning how to basically use the tool.
So, to get to the question,
I'm curious to know
if you have a specific
Snapchat content strategy?
- [Gary] Are you wearing
a Snapchat T-shirt? (laughter)
- I am.
- [Gary] Jeez.
Amazing.
- And I cannot tell you,
I have literally had probably,
I'm gonna guess here,
maybe 30 people that
have connected with me
as a result of just
wearing this T-shirt.
- [Gary] Sure, they did
the screen, yeah.
- Yeah.
But I'm curious to know if you've got
a specific content strategy for Snapchat?
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Kerwin] Outside of
just providing value,
like is it, like, you try to have
a frequency there, is
there something specific
that you're tryin' to go for?
- No!
I use it where I know that
something else can't do it.
So on days I'm doing DailyVee
and I know DRock's there,
I don't have to
document as much,
because I know that's taken care of it,
but when I'm traveling like I
am right now, I'll do it more.
But what it's really there for,
and I wonder if Anchor's
gonna do this for me as well,
is it allows me to not lose
the 80,000 things I wanted to tell
all of you over the last seven years,
that I didn't, because I didn't put it
in Twitter form, I didn't
put it in Youtube form,
but Snapchat, like, yesterdays'
Snapchat secret rant
brought a lot of value
to a lot of people,
I got hunderds of emails.
Right?
And so, that wouldn't have happened
without Snapchat, I wouldn't
have done that in Twitter form.
So, I'm using it for when I feel
that there's no other outlet for it,
but there's no direct strategy,
like I'm gonna post seven times a day,
at these timezones,
because my users are in China,
and here in the US like.
I don't do that, becase that, again,
is good, and you can do that,
and people should do that
and it's fine, it's just not what I do.
- Do you think it's possible, and I know
I'm gonna--
- [Gary] Yes, I definitely
think it's possible!
- Do you think it's
possible to snap too much?
- If it's good, no, if it's not, yes.
People will watch a four hour movie
if it's great, nobody's gone there
and they're wrong, I might make one
just to prove it. (laughter)
And, they will get out
of a six second Vine
two seconds in, if it sucks.
People are always trying to look for,
"Gary, what are the nine
rules of a good snap?"
Guys, it's value!
If you're great,
I can fucking stream 24 hours a day
and pull it off, 'cause I got
a lot of value. (laughter)
Really!
But probably I'd run out, too, right?
Like, it just comes
down to how much value
can you bring to the audience.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
Three.
- [Voiceover] I actually
appreciate it when you swear.
- Thanks man.
(laughter)
- So, my name is Myles Binford,
I wanna talk to the investor
side of you for a second.
- [Gary] Okay.
Oh, please wrap up.
- You mentioned the market
correction (laughter)
that's happening in the venture--
- [Gary] Hold on,
let me take a picture,
this is pretty funny.
What, go ahead, venture side of me.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
So, you mentioned the correction
that's kind of happening
at the venture end,
so.
- [Gary] Yes!
- [Myles] Coming up
here, what is your take
on what's happening
and the fund raising
side of things and for a
serial startup entrepreneur
trying to raise funds, do
you think it's gonna be hard
to raise funds as a startup?
- [Gary] Yes!
- [Myles] Or, later on?
- Definitely?
- I think that the market
is in a place where--
- Where's the market, Gary? (laughter)
- The market's at a place where
every entrepreneur's getting exposed
'cause money's getting harder
and so if you're good enough,
you'll raise money, but if you're not,
you won't as easily.
- Fantastic.
- You're welcome. (laughter)
- [Myles] Okay.
- So, (audience cheers),
whether it's a SaaS tech product
or a product or if it's just you, Johnny,
it doesn't matter what it is,
their money's drying up because
the supply and demand is off-kilter.
- [Myles] Okay.
- Yeah.
Awesome, thanks man.
Two.
- [Voiceover] Hi, Gary!
- Hi!
- [Voiceover] My name is Roberta Ross
and--
- [Gary] Hey, Roberta!
- [Voiceover] Thank you
very much for your message,
it's--
- [Gary] Do you love it?
- [Roberta] It's a gift to
the world, it really is.
- [Gary] To the world?
- Yes, to the world. (laughter)
One audience at a time.
- [Gary] That's right.
Go ahead.
- My only exposure to you before this
was an interview you did of Seth Godin,
so I hadn't heard your story--
- [Gary] And did you feel like
I was into--
- [Roberta] A quarter Russian,
so we have that--
- [Gary] Was that on my show
or something--
- [Roberta] It was on yours,
yes.
- [Gary] And did you feel
like I was--
- But he promoted it.
- And I was interrupting
him too much? (laughter)
- [Roberta] You were
interrupting him a lot,
yeah.
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Roberta] But in a good way. (laughs)
- Oh, good, thank you!
Thank you for figuring me out,
even some of my own fans didn't,
I'm very mad at you.
Okay, go ahead.
- So, I feel like your message
is something that I've on the path of,
I've been an entrepreneur
for over 20 years,
I've been a business coach,
and I've been taking
people on this journey,
helping them recognize their value,
make more money and be happy.
And so, the big hook for people
that I feel like to get their attention
is I, my brand is Six
Figure Real Estate Coach,
that's the name of my company,
and I coach a lot of real estate agents
and solopreneurs.
And so, I know that they wanna make
more money, so I do that for them
to get that attention
and it's not--
- [Gary] And then you trick 'em!
- It's not a bait-and-switch,
it's not a bait-and-switch!
- [Gary] But it is!
I love, I do it, too!
- It's a bait-and-add.
- [Gary] My entire personality
is a bait-and-switch.
- Okay. (laughter)
Maybe, then maybe
this might be moot,
but I was interested
in your opinion,
because I struggled
a little bit with the brand.
- [Gary] Because the name
is so, yeah, like, 'cause
I think you're a spambot.
- That I'm a spambot?
- Yes.
Because anybody's
brand that's six figure
or seven figure this,
I think is crap.
But, but!
- [Roberta] Okay.
- [Gary] 40% of people hate me
the first time they
ever consume me,
so I'm hearing you and saying,
ooh, I like that,
I see what she's doing,
that's what I do.
- So, great, because
when I first heard you
I was like,
not it, not it.
- [Gary] Yeah, he's a jerk.
- [Roberta] And then I
listened more, because
Seth was next to you--
- [Gary] Think about how great
this is, we both felt the same way
about each other.
- Isn't that so interesting?
(laughter)
See, we just gotta not prejudge, right?
We have a deeper bond.
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Roberta] So, maybe then I don't need
to do anything.
So, there's a part of
me that even though
I'm letting go that
transactional approach.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And I'm just putting stuff out there,
I just wanna lift people up, I want them
to recognize their value--
- [Gary] You're talking about
your actual, so you're saying,
"Now I'm giving good advice,
"some people used to come in
"and have to pay for some of that,
"but now I'm putting it out there."
- [Roberta] Well, as a coach,
they have to pay for it, if they want
one-on-one attention.
- [Gary] Of course,
that's right, yep.
- But yes, so I'm just
putting it out there,
even--
- [Gary] You should!
- [Roberta] Like, I have people posting
things and I don't ask for anything,
they even say,
"Go like my Facebook page,"
I'm like, don't even put that on!
So, my question is,
I have a hard time letting go
of the brand, because I know
that it gets--
- [Gary] It's your identity?
- [Roberta] Attention, it's not really
mine, I mean,
I invested six years into it.
- [Gary] Well it is, yeah.
- [Roberta] But it's still (mumbles),
like I'm afraid to let it go,
because I wanna make sure--
- [Gary] Because it's working!
- [Roberta] Yes!
- 'Cause you're bottom feeding.
(Roberta laughs)
- Well actually I feel
like because I'm
speaking from the heart
and I want other people, too--
- [Gary] No, because you're
speaking to a vanity
that many people want.
That's what you're speaking to, darling.
- I'm referring not to the brand,
I'm referring to the message.
- [Gary] No, no, so--
- The message
when I'm a speaker--
- [Gary] Got it!
- [Roberta] And when I speak.
- You're saying that, "I don't feel great
"about myself in how I
get them in the door,
"but once I get them in the door,
"I feel great."
- [Roberta] Okay, yeah,
that's probably true.
- It is true, that's what you're saying.
Everybody knows this,
(Roberta laughs)
so let's get it grounded.
Okay.
Now the question becomes.
- So the question is,
my, I feel--
- [Gary] Are you hoping,
let me ask you a question,
are you hoping
that by putting out good
content, that that might become
the gateway drug, instead of the brand?
- I feel like the shift in me
and what I'm putting out is attracting
the people that I want to work with,
more and more and more--
- [Gary] Instead of,
because you were getting a
different kind of person before.
- More of a range.
But now it's narrowing.
- [Gary] No, no, not more
range, you were getting people
that were attracted to Six
Figure Real Estate Coach
because people that are attracted
to the brand Six Figure
Real Estate Coach
are the people that don't want
to do anything that is real,
and they want shortcuts
to get to six figures.
- So, that's my, so my question is,
I guess I have your opinion,
but should I change it,
even though--
- [Gary] That's not,
that's not my thing to say.
We all know that
you wanna change it.
My thing is, you should change it
for a couple of months,
you can always go back to it.
How you make your money
matters more than how much you make.
To me, and by the way,
and by the way.
- [Roberta] Yes, I like that.
- [Gary] It does not have to to you,
I have no interest in judging you,
you have to judge you.
But I know anybody who ever asks
me that question wants to be on this side
of the equation. Because there's plenty
of six figure other things that don't
wanna ask the question.
Got it?
- Yes.
- [Gary] I know you do.
- Yes, thank you,
and one more question.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
Yes!
- [Gary] That was so profound,
I thought that was a good place to end.
(laughter and cheers)
Now you're gonna ask
like how many characters
should I use in a tweet?
No, it was so perfect,
but I'm just kidding, go
ahead, what do you got?
- I do wanna get a picture.
- [Gary] Yes, you could do that.
- And I've been interviewing people
for about six years for a series
I do, and I would
love to interview you.
I'm shaming you in front
of all these people.
- [Gary] Well, the good news
is you're not shaming me
because what you're asking for
is a very valuable asset,
which is the brand association
and right now time
is a problem for me.
But, if you stay very hardcore
and keep persisting, I do buckle
under most circumstances. (laughter)
- Okay. (laughs heartily)
- I'm gonna do the book signing.
Listen, I've got a full hour
to do either book signing,
or selfie, you pick.
Thank you very much,
ICON! (audience cheers)